>> DEMOCRATS ARE READY TO GO OFF
THE DEEP END ON IMPEACHMENT.
ALMOST HALF HOUSE DEMOCRATS WANT
AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
JERRY NADLER IS ONE OF THE
DEMOCRATS LEADING THE CHARGE.
>> MY PERSONAL VIEW IS THAT HE
DESERVES IMPEACHMENT.
HE HAS DONE MANY IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES.
THAT'S NOT THE QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS, CAN WE DEVELOP
ENOUGH EVIDENCE BEFORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> WELL, DEMOCRATS CAN'T COME TO
GRIPS WITH THE FACT THAT
MUELLER'S TESTIMONY WAS A TOTAL
FLOP.
IT DIDN'T MOVE THE NEEDLE TO
CHANGE THEIR VIEWS ON
IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S NO SURPRISE.
EVERYBODY IS PRETTY LOCKED IN.
BUT WHAT JERRY NADLER SAID
INTERESTED ME.
AFTER TWO YEARS, MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITH 17 LAWYERS, THEY
STILL HAVEN'T DEVELOPED ENOUGH
EVIDENCE THAT HE COMMITTED HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
DO YOU THINK WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN
BY NOW QUESTION WORK >> I THINK
HE SAID THAT HE BELIEVES THERE
IS JUSTIFICATION FOR
IMPEACHMENT, BUT HE WANTS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SEE IT.
THIS IS A POLITICAL ACT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A COURT OF
LAW.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHAT HE WANTS TO BUILD IS A
CASE IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
PERCEPTION.
BY THE WAY COMING YOU ARE WRONG.
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC PRESSURE IT'S
LIKE 65-75% OF DEMOCRATS WHO
THINK THAT HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE BROADER
AUDIENCE, THEY DON'T THINK THAT.
>> NO ONE'S OPINIONS CHANGED.
>> WHAT YOU SEE IS THIS LIKE TO
TAKE UP IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO SAID HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
MY THOUGHT IS THAT NANCY PELOSI
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT PLAYER.
SHE DOESN'T SEE IMPEACHMENT AS
ADVANCING DEMOCRATIC POLICIES OR
DEMOCRATIC POLITICS.
THE POLITICS, I THINK FROM
NANCY PELOSI'S VIEW IS, BEAT HIM
AT ELECTION TIME.
OH, THE PRESS.
THEY ARE AFTER ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT, JUST BEAT HIM AT
THE POLLS.
PEOPLE WANT TO FIRE HIM.
>> THAT'S FINE.
>> OH, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> DID WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT HIS
POINT NOW THAT PELOSI HAS
ATTEMPTED TO QUIET THE
IMPEACHMENT PUSH?
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE DEAD AFTER
THE MUELLER HEARINGS.
>> THEY ARE STILL DOING THE
PSEUDO-IMPEACHMENT WITHOUT
REALLY DOING IMPEACHMENT.
THEY ARE CLAIMING THAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT OVERSIGHT WITH JERRY
NADLER.
HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED AND
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT OF ALL
THESE CRIMES.
IF WE AREN'T GOING TO SEE ANY
CHANGE IN PEOPLE'S OPINIONS
AFTER MUELLER TESTIFIED.
THE REPORT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE END.
THAT WASN'T SATISFYING ENOUGH.
THEN THEY BRING HIM IN TO
TESTIFY, THAT WAS A COMPLETE
DISASTER, TRAIN WRECK.
NOW, SHE'S TRYING AGAIN TO
BALANCE OUT THE 75% OF THE
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT IMPEACHMENT
WITH THE MODERATES WHO WERE
VOTED IN IN 2018 THAT SHE WOULD
LIKE TO WIN AGAIN IN 2020.
>> DO YOU THINK HE'S TRYING TO
GO CARD LEFT?
>> IS THAT A CONSPIRACY THEORY
OR IS THAT REAL?
>> Dana: I SAW SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT JERRY NADLER
IS THAT WORRIED.
REMEMBER, HE JUST SENT A
SURROGATE TO THE DEBATES.
HE DIDN'T CARE.
MAYBE NADLER WILL PAY MORE
ATTENTION.
NANCY PELOSI, ON THE OTHER HAND
SAID THAT AUGUST IS GOING TO BE
THE MONTH THAT THEY WIN.
SHE'S GOING TO FOCUS EXCLUSIVELY
ON HEALTH CARE.
ONE THING SHE DOES HAVE ON HER
FAVORITE IS DESPITE ALL THE
PRESSURE, DEMOCRATS HAVE RAISED
A TON OF MONEY.
THEY ARE WAY AHEAD OF THEIR
REPUBLICAN COUNTERPARTS.
>> REALLY?
OH.
WOW.
GREG.
>> PRETEND LIKE SHE DID NOT SAY
THAT.
TO GO AGAIN, THIS IS HER
RESPONSE AFTER THE MUELLER
FIASCO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IMPEACHMENT IS?
I DON'T THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY REALLY WANT.
IF THEY GET IT, THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO WANT TO.
HAVE YOU EVER RUN TILL MIKE RAN
AWAY FROM HOME, YOU MAKE IT LIKE
ONE BLOCK, AND THEN YOU SIT ON
THE CURB.
A KIND OF MISS MY PARENTS AND
THAT MEET MEAT LOAF.
DEMOCRATS JUST WANT TO SAY THERE
RUNNING AWAY FROM HOME.
THEY REALLY DON'T WANT TO RUN
AWAY FROM HOME.
I THINK THAT IT WILL TURN HIM
INTO A MARTYR.
IT WILL HELP HIM THE WAY IT
HELPED BILL CLINTON.
>> Dana: IT WOULD BE BETTER
FOR THEM ALL IF THEY REALIZE
THAT THE 2016 ELECTIONS REALLY
WERE ABOUT POLICY AND ABOUT
APPROACH AND ABOUT TONE, AND NOT
ABOUT THIS, BECAUSE THEY WERE